thank you so just for getting started
here is there anyone who hasn't heard of
webassembly or azzam alright great
awesome is there anyone here who's
actually had a reason to use webassembly
in a production app okay alright so
we're all about on the same page I'd
like to invite you back in a journey of
time to the year 2017 like most of you I
had heard about webassembly but beyond
some surface level stuff I didn't
actually know very much about it I read
this headline and I thought huh well I
mean I guess if webassembly really does
kill JavaScript then I'll figure that
stuff out but it sure seems like people
have wanted JavaScript to die for a
while now and we're all still here and
besides what does a typical JSF need was
him for anyway well little did I know my
experience was about to take a turn for
the atypical I work for a consulting
firm based here in Seattle called genui
we're in Fremont and we do a lot of
different kinds of work but I think our
dev manager described it best when he
said our web expertise is really in
doing stuff that's a little weird last
year we had one of those weird client
requests and I'd like to tell you the
story about how and why we built a
screen recording and video editing app
for Chrome OS that runs entirely
client-side our requirements were as
follows the app was meant to look and
feel like it was native to Chrome OS and
act as a competitor to other Chrome OS
screen recording apps out there the
client specifically requested that the
app would provide video editing
capability and it needed to run locally
offline there are a couple of ways to
develop for Chrome OS and we decided to
use chrome packaged apps on Chrome OS
packaged apps are essentially just web
apps that are given some additional
hardware related api's at their core
they're just JavaScript HTML and CSS as
we started to investigate how we wanted
to implement the project it was actually
surprised to discover just how much it's
possible to do with media in the
javascript for instance if the user can
sense you can capture their whole screen
or their webcam and then use the native
native recorder api to record that
screen create a video and allow the user
to download it to their machine and
that's possible in any web browser any
modern web browser there's nothing
special about Chromebook that lets you
do it so if all we needed was a screen
recording app then we'd be set with
those tools but the client had requested
some video editing capabilities and as a
result we started to get into a realm of
things that are technically possible in
JavaScript but just not a great idea for
a variety of reasons for instance if you
wanted to create a watermark you can
create a media stream that collects data
from a canvas element you can then draw
your watermark onto every frame of that
water canvas element and then merge it
into the stream from your screen
recording but unsurprisingly it's to
memory intensive so the resulting videos
were kind of like watching a very badly
dubbed foreign film you've got all the
pieces there but they don't line up
another of the video editing features we
wanted to implement was trimming or
shortening the video it turns out you
can actually do that in plain JavaScript
so long as you only want to trim the end
of the video you want to trim the
beginning you're out of luck at least in
Chrome and that brings us to
functionality that simply isn't possible
in native JavaScript once you create
that WebM file from your media recorder
you're done there's no way to add a
watermark or a filter or something else
after the fact it's also not possible to
re-encode the video the media recorder
API will give you a WebM so if you
wanted a gif or an mp4 then you can't do
it with native functionality at this
point we went back to the client and we
recommended a server-side only solution
and there were two big reasons for this
the first is that video editing is a
memory intensive process and Chromebooks
are not powerful machines by design they
are meant to do most
of their work from the clown and the
second is that really client-side video
editing pushes the limit of what's even
possible on the web today we had two
people working on this project we did
not have an infinite budget and we
wanted to deliver something reasonable
the client did take our recommendation
into account but ultimately asked us to
move ahead with a client side only
implementation this set us off on a
journey to discover the limits of what's
actually possible on the web today since
we had already determined that video
editing isn't possible in native
JavaScript we needed to find a way to
run code that is not native javascript
in the browser and web assembly is by no
means the first tool that allows you to
do this in fact running non J's code in
the browser has a long history
does anyone here remember a little thing
obscure called flash anyone any
ActionScript devs out there what about
Silverlight I gave away my best joke all
right you may have heard that web
assembly isn't just another way to write
plugins and that's true but without
understanding a little more about
plugins in general it's hard to know why
the comparison is even being made so the
90s are in again let's go back to 1995
we are all wearing janko's and the
slater standing in front of you isn't me
but this guy because you're living on
the cutting edge your browser of choice
is obviously Netscape and Netscape has
just released the Netscape plug-in API
or NPAPI NPAPI is the first way to
develop plug-ins or browser extensions
and to handle media from within the
browser what happened was the browser
would come across content that it
couldn't handle and detect the file type
and then load the appropriate plugin
that plug-in would run in place on your
web page as of today NPAPI is deprecated
in every major browser and that's mostly
due to issues with complexity and
security it's also because the advent of
EML five means that the browser can
handle a lot of kinds of kind of things
natively that would otherwise have been
handled by plugins but plugins didn't
actually fully die with NPAPI in 2009
Google released the pepper plug-in API
or ppapi pepper is a build chain that
produces binary file types called Native
Client and portable Native Client or
NaCl and pnacl get it salt and pepper
portable Native Client was meant to
provide a more secure less complex
alternative to NPAPI with it developers
could recompile libraries written in C
or C++ to a portable Native Client
format and then that could be run from
within the browser and accessed in
JavaScript for those webassembly fans in
the crowd some of that may sound
familiar so why aren't we all talking
about pepper and how it hearkens the
death of the most widely used
programming language in the world today
well an open standard for pepper was
never created the resulting portable
Native Client files were only ever
supported on Chrome chromium and bling
based browsers as of today portable
Native Client is deprecated for every
platform except Chromebook but then of
course we were building for Chromebooks
so let's put a pin in that that brings
us to today and webassembly
like portable Native Client webassembly
takes advantage of common hardware
capabilities to deliver native or near
native performance the EM script and
build chain allows developers to convert
libraries written not only in C or C++
but also rust into a wasm format that
runs from within the browser developers
can even write directly in web assembly
for all you super nerds out there who
just can't get enough of assembly
language unlike pepper web assembly is
an open standard and it's been adopted
by every modern browser so it's really
something that you can use and deliver
to the vast majority of the web but that
doesn't actually say so much about
what's great about web assembly in the
first place or why we would want to use
C or C++ there are really a couple of
reasons why you might use web assembly
in your application
the first of these is performance
performance on webassembly in general is
much faster than native JavaScript and
that's mostly due to a lack of dynamic
typing and webassembly
of course if you're interested there are
many many other talks that you can look
into on the subject and I strongly
recommend Lynne Clarke's cartoon
introduction to web assembly or for that
matter any of Lynne's talks due to
performance considerations you might
look into a web assembly if you have a
particularly heavy operation that you
could perform in JavaScript but you
would prefer not to
for instance every single page web
application framework that most of us in
this room use has some kind of a Dom
dipping operation it's a heavy thing to
do and it can have negative performance
implications for updating your page
particularly in component heavy
scenarios glimmer which is the Dom
rendering engine by the Ember team has
an existing build that leverages web
assembly for this purpose and that is a
methodology that should ultimately rely
so in a much faster rendering engine and
I'm definitely not just saying that
because you who to Katz who is the
primary architect of glimmer is speaking
later today there are folks who are
looking into this for react as well
performance aside the second reason you
might want to use wisdom speaks to our
problem with video editing as we
discussed earlier you can't really edit
video in JavaScript but you absolutely
can edit video in C++ in fact you can do
several things in C++ or rust that are
outside the current capabilities of
modern browsers that includes not just
video editing but also audio editing
platform emulation and a number of
different kinds of games lazon was
literally built for our use case and so
now we just needed to choose a video
editing library that we could use it was
important to find a library because as I
mentioned earlier there were only two of
us and we had neither the budget nor the
expertise to build something by
ourselves from scratch it turns out
there aren't actually tons of video
editing options in either C++ or rust
and that may be due in part to the
tremendous popularity of ffmpeg which is
an open source multimedia library
written in C++ ffmpeg is a command-line
tool that support
adding watermarks or trimming or
cropping video or just about any other
kind of thing that you might want to do
with it our early research indicated
that ffmpeg could be used through either
portable Native Client or webassembly
and ultimately we were unable to find
another good candidate naturally it's
chase devs the first thing we did was go
to the NPM registry and actually there
is an ffmpeg j/s so let's take a look at
that github page this looks pretty good
right and actually I am hugely grateful
to get hub user Kagame who is the author
of this package and also picture Romanov
who forked it and added some extra
documentation without these folks we
really would have been lost but these
were enough bread comes for us to sort
of figure out how to do this but getting
back to my NPM install I saw a couple of
concerning things right off the bat
first is the size the entirety of ffmpeg
even when compiled is about 15 megabytes
that is way too much to load when we're
loading the app and it is a lot to ask
users to download from the chrome store
to begin one the default build also
includes tons of functionality we didn't
plan on using it also includes the h.264
codec which as of last year was still
patented we needed a binary that was
compiled without it and second the
version of ffmpeg that this library is
based on is an old one this is a couple
years old so we came to the conclusion
that even though there is an existing
NPM install for this library we still
needed to compile our own wasm file this
is the point at which we started to get
into technologies that Jas devs don't
tend to use on a day to day basis and
the first of these is called M script in
M script in is a build chain SDK just
like pepper and for those of you who
haven't done a lot of this kind of thing
it's vaguely analogous to a tool like
babel m script in is a command-line tool
that takes on compiled c++ library and
builds it in such a way that awasum is
produced you can pass in various build
options when you use it so if for
instance you wanted to build your wiesen
binary in such a way that it's
compatible with web workers you would do
that as a part of your overall m script
and build command so that's that's a lot
of high-level information let's
get down and take a look at something
concrete the following example is a
little hello world written in C like
most of you I don't really program in C
on a day-to-day basis or ever but we can
look at what's here and determine what
it does easily enough the main method is
what's runs when the app loads we've
imported the standard input/output
library and then just used it to print
our hello world and it's the application
this would print to your console and
actually in our app we'll print to the
JavaScript console too but will also
display it in the Dom now we need to
compile our hello world to a wasm file
you can do that in M script in by using
the following command you can see here
that we do need to specify wasm and
that's because M scripting can compile
to other formats - such as a s MJS also
- o output 'html
let's M script - note that I actually
want Emscripten
to build my webpage for me rather than
just compile a binary so let's take a
look at that webpage as you can see
there's a lot more going on here than
just hello world by default script ins
output gives you a page with a console
that you can use to see the wasm output
in order to do this it also generates
some JavaScript glue code to connect the
HTML with awasum binary so that seems
simple enough right but if this were say
a Thanksgiving turkey drawing tutorial
then we're at about this step here we've
drawn an outline of our hand and you all
know what comes next right
we don't need HelloWorld
we need ffmpeg and there are more than a
few steps in between but you know like
every now and again things just kind of
work the way you think they should so
it's worth just trying to convert ffmpeg
and see what happens next
first we'll go over a couple of terms
you may not be familiar with make is a
UNIX tool that acts as a task runner
just like go up in the JSE Co system
clang is a front-end interface for
compilation tools and GCC is the GNU
UNIX compiler these all work together to
create executables for many C or C++
libraries including ffmpeg to get
started we need to pull ffmpeg down from
github it's open source so everything's
there this is the root folder of the
ffmpeg library what we need to do is use
the project's make file and have all of
those constructions in substitute clang
and GCC with our own M script and Bill
chain piece of cake right in case you
really did think it was cake please
allow me to assure you that it is not to
help you out M scripting has actually
built their own tool that comes with
their build chain and to help you
substitute M script in for GCC and clang
and C projects it's called M configure
so first we call M configure configure
and that will substitute M script in for
GCC and clang next we'll run em make
make and that should use our hem script
infilling for actually building the
library into LLVM format bit code
assuming everything has gone well this
is the point at which we can run a
command that's similar to our hello
world command from earlier but of course
everything has not gone well after about
20 minutes of compilation and Makemake
has thrown an error and it appears to
generate from deep within the heart of
this massive library anyone who's
struggled to get their builds to
transpile correctly using webpack or
babel knows the pain that can accompany
production builds particularly as they
become more complex building a project
and C really is no different and
compiling that project into a format for
which it was never in
as an even greater degree of complexity
when we're looking at something like our
hello world see from earlier it seems
reasonable to debug the compilation
project process even though we're not
actually see deaths it did not seem
reasonable to debug this giant make file
and delve into the heart of the legacy
media framework so let's make a long
story short M configurate makes a number
of assumptions about your C based build
environment that may or may not be true
for this particular make file it was
necessary to go in and replace every
reference to the existing build chain
with m s-- Krypton ii m s-- Krypton
can't use anything that uses ASM not a s
MJS but just a ASM and that's used in
mini c libraries to provide compiler
instructions to GCC since we're not
actually building with GCC we need to
pass the option to build ffmpeg without
ASM finally Emscripten won't actually
convert every possible combination of
things that can be written in c we had
to patch ffmpeg in a couple of places
just to get the conversion to work at
all in the end however we did prevail so
let's take a look at a demo here we're
looking at a video that has been created
in native javascript through a screen
recording of a youtube clip our media
recorder has returned a blob that we can
convert to a file and then save to the
user's local machine but you'll notice
that we can't seek through this video
and that's not a great user experience
this is due to a chrome specific bug
where their media recorder doesn't
create keyframes as it records therefore
the kind of file that's created doesn't
know important things about itself like
how long it is next you'll recall that
the client wanted to add trim
functionality to our app and that makes
total sense from a user's perspective
we've all started screen recordings
where we forgot to setup our screen and
needed to trim out the first little bit
this is where ffmpeg comes in handy when
we rub our WebM video through ffmpeg
it'll add those missing key frames by
default will also ask ffmpeg to trim our
video to its desired length when we're
sending it to web assembly it looks a
little like this
I've compiled my ffmpeg build so that it
works with web workers and then I'll
create a new web worker I will listen to
make sure that worker is ready and once
everything is loaded I'll post a message
that contains all the information that
ffmpeg needs to kick off a trim
operation we can see that the type of
thing that I want to run is called run
and that's the default or main method in
ffmpeg and I've passed in some data
which is actually as a array buffer
finally I pass in the same arguments
that I would pass in if I were using
ffmpeg from the command line so we've
got a - SS that's where you're starting
your video - T that's how long your
video will be and then - C copy just
means we want to use the existing codec
let's see what that looks like when it's
applied to our video all right so I've
kicked off the ffmpeg process by default
in the background and we can see that
before too long we get a little video
it's obviously different than it was
before it's only two seconds long so
that being said there are some important
caveats for using this technology the
last video editing feature requested by
our client was to provide crop and
that's in case the user wants to only
display a portion of what they've
created in their video and you can see
it we've we've kicked off our operation
we're getting lots of logging output
from ffmpeg that's great we know that
something is happening but you know like
minutes only that video is only a minute
long and we're still watching it convert
so we obviously can't put that in front
of a user what's up the other operations
were really fast and I told you earlier
that performance and web assembly is
supposed to be much better right well
there are two things happening here that
cause performance issues and one is just
that re-encoding takes a little more
time than costing copying the existing
codec this operation would be a little
slower from the command line as well but
not by a factor of about a thousand
which is what we have here it turns out
that when Emscripten performs this
conversion
there are a few patterns in C++ that
will convert but have tremendously
negative performance implications for
instance code that relies on x86 lineman
behavior or code that makes use of set
jump to say the execution context and
yes
I had to look that stuff up so in theory
could we address these performance
issues and patch them in the same way we
patched the code that was causing
conversion problems or maybe we could
add in web assembly specific compilation
optimizations to compensate for
compiling without ASM but truth is I
don't really know we did not have the
budget to become all unknowing video
encoding plasm converting masters and
who does really it's also worth
mentioning that winweb assembly ship to
all major browsers it shipped as an MVP
there's a ton of functionality coming
down the pipeline that might help to
support some of the issues we had with
ffmpeg one of these is multi-threaded
support which would almost certainly
make the re-encoding process faster wasm
is also looking to support garbage
collection which will open the door to
converting language as well beyond just
C++ and rust ultimately since we were on
the Chromebook platform we took a look
at using the pepper build chain in
portable Native Client an ffmpeg
conversion process is already well
defined there and the result is quite a
bit faster than our webassembly binary
although perhaps unsurprisingly the more
performance heavy conversions still take
some time and still produce an
unacceptable user experience on
Chromebooks due to their lightweight
processors so is this a story about why
you shouldn't use webassembly
not at all we learned a lot and I wanted
to share those takeaways with you first
ffmpeg was almost certainly the wrong
library to start learning about web
assembly and C++ in the first place
there are several existing was important
and you can find them on github next if
you're evaluating a new C++ library that
you think you'd like to use then there
are some well-known patterns you can
check for to give you a good idea about
whether you should proceed portability
guidelines and API limitations can be
found on the Emscripten
site and this is a case where it's a
good idea to tap someone with some C++
expertise to help you determine whether
your library of choice contains those
patterns and how difficult it might be
to patch them finally the rest language
was specifically designed with the web
in mind and it looks to support wasum as
a first-class compilation target if the
functionality you're looking for exists
in both C++ and rust it's probably
worthwhile to start with rust web
assembly is an exciting new tool that
opens a new world of functionality and
performance and it's helping to pave the
way to using the browser is a true
application platform but for the average
j/s dev converting functionality into
web assembly is still a pretty big ask
it's tremendously helpful to have access
to expertise in both the source code
getting converted as well as the
intended use of that functionality as
wasum becomes more mainstream I expect
to see better tooling more libraries and
simpler processes become more prevalent
in the meantime we may all be consuming
web assembly through frameworks long
before we ever have a reason to create
anything ourselves thank you